before we go into possible theories as
to why plates actually move what i want
to do in this video is think a little
bit about why we see the geological
features we do see at plate boundaries
and in particular i want to focus on the
the the features we see at divergent
plate boundaries where the plates are
moving away from each other where new
land is being created like we saw in the
mid oceanic uh ridges where we see new
land being created right in the center
and moving outwards from them so to do
that let's think about the different
layers
let's think about the different layers
and actually i want to make one quick
correction on the last video over here i
had drawn these arrows going in that
direction and based on how i defined
them they should be going into the page
and so they should have had these x's
there now with that out of the way let's
draw a little diagram of what happens at
kind of
at the early stages of these divergent
plate boundaries so you might have your
you might here you have just your crust
and maybe it's continental crust
so this right here is the earth's
the earth's crust and then you have the
salad you have the solid part of the
mantle and the combination of them is
the lithosphere
lithosphere
and then you have the liquid part or the
super hot part of the mantle so this
down here is
magma it hasn't solidified it's hot
enough to be in the liquid state and all
of this combined so this right here we
consider the mantle
mantle now there's some debate and we'll
talk about this in the next video of how
hot spots actually form it could be
these mantle plumes that start at the
the border between the mantle and the
core it could be some type of convection
currents in the actual mantle we'll talk
more about that in the next video or
maybe a few videos from now
but let's take it for granted that hot
spots form in the mantle so let's say we
have an area of of magma right here that
is particularly hot let me draw it let
me do this in another cauldron in pink
so this is particularly
hot magma here and we know or maybe we
don't know well you learn node right now
if you take the same material and you
make it hotter it's going to become less
dense because the particles essentially
are going to bump into each other with
more kinetic energy and have more space
in between them and so this really hot
part of the magma this really hot part
of the mantle it is going to move
upwards it is going to move upwards
because it is less dense it will have
buoyancy and as it moves upwards it will
heat up the things around it and it'll
eventually make its way into the
lithosphere and it'll kind of be able to
break through the lithosphere because
it's so hot it can kind of melt its way
through so let's fast forward this
let's fast forward this a little bit so
this is step one up here now step two
this hot this hot magma is rising now
through the lithosphere and so it's
going to create a hot spot it's going to
create a dome in the lithosphere and
actually on the crust and so it might
look like this
so the crust is now going to have a dome
in it
and this was the original this is the
original lithosphere and it's now kind
of been broken into by this hot spot
so the lithosphere
the lithosphere is now broken into
or it's about to be broken into by this
hot spot so all of this is still the
lithosphere i'll just write litho for
short this up here is the crust
and if you take any rigid material and
the crust and the lithosphere for that
matter they're rigid and you push
outward on it it won't stretch nicely
like a nice elastic balloon it'll start
to crack and have to be pulled apart in
order to kind of take the the pushing
from below so this crust this crust is
going to start to crack and actually the
best example where you see this is
actually in like sourdough bread that
has really hard shells around it you see
sourdough bread let me see if i can draw
a roll of sourdough bread it has all of
these it has these cracks in the surface
and that's because the outer layer the
outer shell of the bread is really rigid
and so when the inside heats up and the
surface area has to expand these kind of
riffs form
these rifts form in the bread to allow
that kind of rigid shell to actually to
actually expand and that exact same
thing would happen to the crust or
actually the entire lithosphere so let
me draw this hot spot again
so now the hot spot i want to do that
pink color
now the hot spot has gotten this far
this is the hot magma
right over here and if we fast forward a
little bit if we fast forward even a
little bit more
then you could actually have the crust
started to be fully pulled apart so you
fast forward a little bit more about the
bottom boundary of the lithosphere maybe
now starts to look something like this
the the the man the magma has kind of
broken through
the the hardened part the rigid part of
the mantle so maybe it looks like this
maybe it looks like this right now you
have your hot
you have your
the hot spot right over here it's gotten
that far now
it's gotten that far and the crust on
top
the actual what we would kind of you
know what we normally see has now been
pulled apart to kind of have to cover
this new surface area so now it kind of
looks something like this so it's been
pushed apart
let me see how well i can draw this
so now it's been pushed apart and as it
gets pushed apart it kind of thins out a
little bit as you can imagine it doing
it's it's almost exactly as the bread
analogy when you look at bread like this
the rift the parts that the depressions
where it was expanding most vigorously
those parts of the bread are actually
thinner like these parts of the bread
are actually thinner and they're not as
hard as the parts that moved away and
you see that exact same thing happening
with the land
and you see that exact same thing
happening in land and all of this stuff
is going to start getting pushed
all of this stuff is continuously
getting pushed outward essentially to
kind of make space for this hot spot now
at this step right over here you might
have a volcano or two but more important
you're going to have what's called a
rift valley
right now we're assuming that we're not
below sea level yet or we're assuming
that this kind of depression in the land
that you see here hasn't come in contact
with another body of water and so it'll
just kind of become a little valley in
between higher land and you actually see
that on
on earth and the most famous is the
great is the african rift valley that's
right about
right about this region here actually
have a better diagram that depicts the
african rift valley
right over here it's this whole region
of africa is actually kind of a big
valley created by a hot spot
created by a hot spot right over there
now as the hot spot kind of keeps
maturing eventually
eventually some of the rift
eventually some of the rift will become
so depressed that'll actually be below
sea level remember all this land up here
is being stretched is being stretched
apart so let me go to the next step the
next step will be right over here the
land on top is now
is now maybe below sea level and this
next step and it comes in contact with
the maybe an ocean or a sea and so now
it might look like this
so now the land is super thin
on top
do my best to draw it so it's super thin
on top and remember it's it's kind of
keeps getting pulled apart
it keeps getting pulled apart
from this bubble of hot of hot magma
that's essentially that's coming up from
below
let me draw it like this
this is all solid rock here what i do in
orange is the crust this is kind of the
rocky part and actually i should draw it
this is the rocky part of the of the
mantle so the combination is the
lithosphere and now you have the hot
hot magma coming up like this and it
might peak through every now and then
create a volcano there maybe it'll peek
through and create a volcano there but
in general it's going to keep it's keep
going to keep pushing the land up and
outwards and so this land even though
you're saying hey it's being pushed up
because of the outward motion this land
over here is going to be lower than the
land around it like the loaf of bread if
it gets low enough and comes in and
below sea level actually and it comes in
contact with a body of water
or even if it doesn't actually water
will start to gather over there
water will start to gather
and once again we actually see that
we actually see that in the rift forming
in the rift forming between the african
and arabian plates the red sea is
actually an example of exactly that the
arabian plate is moving away from the
african plate because of this hot spot
this this is pushing all of the land up
and out right over here and so this is
going out that is going out it's moving
outward in every direction and so it
creates these depressions where water
can flow inwards the the rift valley
hasn't had water flow into it the way
the red sea has just yet but if it kept
happening eventually it's going to get
low enough so that the water will flow
into it so the red sea is exactly that
you essentially have the indian ocean
flowing into this rift that formed from
this hot spot and then if you fast
forward a bunch so that finally the
magma can kind of surface so let's fast
forward from even this point even more
so let's fast forward even more and
let's say now the land has been pushed a
good bit apart
now the hot spot is actually surfaced
now the crust might look something like
this
the crust might look something like this
so it's been pushed apart a good bit at
this point you know now we're talking
about on the order of of of hundreds of
thousands of years or tens of thousands
of years so the land for example the
land that was here this part of the land
might now be out here
and this part of the land might not
might now be out here what's going to
happen is that this hot spot
this hot spot is going to continue to
fuel and we're assuming everything's
under water at this point since this
depression that was created is now so
low the crust was stretched thin
we're going to assume that all of this
is under water the hot spot is
essentially going to is
essentially going to come out of
underwater volcanoes it's going to come
out of underwater volcanoes and start
creating and start creating what's now
this body of water has gotten large
enough that we could call it a
mid-oceanic ridge and so it'll actually
start creating let's do this in a
different color it'll start creating an
actual ridge
it'll actually create a ridge with
volcanoes in the center and so that's
why
that's why one we see things like
we see things like the the afro the the
rift valley in africa we see things like
the red sea and maybe even more
importantly that's why we see something
like the mid
rift in the middle of the atlantic ocean
where you have all of this depressed
land that was essentially analogous to
that rift valley but it's at a much
later stage and that's what and that's
why it's able to collect water because
when the land was pushed out and
stretched thin water was able to flow
into it going back to the bread analogy
it's essentially
when this bread was baking and this part
of the surf the crust pushed outwards
you had this rift form and then if there
was some water on the bread if it was
raining or if it was connected to a body
of water water would have eventually
flown would have actually flowed in here
and if that bread kept growing this rift
would have kept growing eventually to
the size of the atlantic ocean in our in
our theoretical bread and so that's why
you have this huge depressed area where
the ocean can form but in the middle of
it you kind of have this you have this
submersed you have this actual submerged
mountain chain this is the submersed
chain of volcanoes this submersed ridge
where the land actually does go up a
little bit because of all that magma
flowing directly out of it so hopefully
that clears up a little bit that was
always confusing to me why you see
uplifted land but then everything around
the uplifted land is uh much lower and
why the whole thing is submerged as it's
moving away so hopefully that cleared
things up a little bit